[Applauso]
[Musica]
quand'era piccola sognava di lavorare in
una biblioteca era convinta che di platì
care fossero molte fortunati ogni giorno
hanno accesso ad una montagna di tesori
ora potevano e possono leggere storie
meravigliose scoprire popoli entry cifre
e soprattutto viaggiare attraverso il
tempo
il mondo si inserì inizia quando sono
cresciuto ho trovato la mia espressione
del mondo e dell'arte
ho iniziato a studiare in una scuola
d'arte
dopotutto a prendere grandi artisti di
differente tecniche sono cresciuto
ammirando miti vangelo voti cln rubens
ma l'artista che diventate più
significative per me è la nord da vinci
una leggenda anche di vole ingegner
artista astro nano sono state poi ho
studiato perché di mira anche getur
filmaker sculture e probabilmente
lavorata il mondo dell'animazione
l'espressione in tutti i cristiani
mi sono lasciata e sfiorare di grandi
maestri e maestre che combinava
perfettamente l'arte scienze e
tecnologie sono state tutte esperienze
spectacular e ma comuni artist voleva
qualcosa di più
cercava qualcosa di differente qualcosa
di magico
due anni fa per caso bisogna battute in
realtà virtuale
r sorprese ed affascinata la possibilità
limitate
chi ne prospettavano ad avanzi che nel
dir metteva nei mie sogni in realtà
adesso faccio performance tuccillo
angolo della terra
e questo era uno dei miei sogni lavorate
in stati diversi
parlando invii di firenze consegnare ad
imparare e creare qualcosa di unico
oggi per una cima venite in mia mondo o
cognato nuovo termine per definire la
mia arte volumi sman il volo mismo è
caratterizzato per creazione del
competizione in realtà virtuale tu puoi
creare qualsisi volume grande come le
può immaginare non ciliegie di entrare
età e le possibilità sono infinite
tu puoi dakar l'anima di spettatore in
modo diversi chi è da confermare
prova a far cambiare può applicare le
regole tradizionali dell'arte o creare
de nuova può assumere qualunque forma
delle trata alla strada è uno strumento
è pazzesco tu puoi entrare in dipinta
quasi toccare ogni signora pignolata via
vitt
il mio mondo dove in particolare fa sua
neither in cappelle per una strana
signora dopo il nero il colore della
gioia dove non ci sono regole e poi
creare qualunque cosa che va dai geni
ogni tanto
chiede qualcosa tutt diventa assurda hai
lavorato come un pazzo
il tuo cliente non ha alcuna logica
riesci più capire
nessun in nessuno capisci te
e allora inviarsi dei monti te ne vai il
mondo virtuale non vuol dire che
scappando e dei problemi
cambia semplicemente tuia energia
espressi te esprimete stesse in modo
nuovo e quando sarah è delle torna il
mondo reale
puoi prendere decisioni migliori live id
e mai non solo bianco on air per me
crest roso sporco della fiat alla lite
qualcosa tra la nascita e la morte
questo lavoro rappresenta facilità the
preacher e trascendenza della vita
il simbolismo è l'arma dall arte l'arte
deporre de maglie come ogni artista mi
chiedo dove quando come chi il tè
virtuale è solo uno strumento un mezzo
con un pennello o una terra
tutto dipende tua immaginazione
immaginazione
quest immagine della vita non ha idee
che cosa diventerai kiss eroi o dove
occupando e questa è estremamente
affascinante nostro è nulla del domani
il mio augurio che continuare a segnare
e nelle vie e soprattutto i vostri sogni
di vinci va realta come me grazie